un día bastante activo empezó con esta
reunión en la NASA donde se reunió con
la vicepresidenta kamala Harris allá
discutieron de los intereses conjuntos
entre Francia y Estados Unidos en la
carrera espacial y los retos que hay de
Cara a esta nueva esfera donde se están
planteando según Manuel macron
presidente francés pues nuevos
conflictos que se tendrán que abordar
Ojalá de forma conjunta como lo mencionó
varias veces en este encuentro con la
vicepresidenta Manuel macron estuvo
también en el congreso tuvo un almuerzo
de trabajo con senadores y
representantes a la cámara tanto
republicanos como demócratas también con
líderes de la comunidad y con líderes
empresariales después estuvo en el
cementerio de Arlington donde visitó la
tumba de el ingeniero Pierre lanfa este
señor pues fue además el que diseñó y
planificó la ciudad de Washington que
tiene varios edificios muy importantes
que tienen arquitectura bastante
francesa y después se reunió con la
comunidad francesa acá en Washington
Cristóbal para mañana también se espera
una agenda muy apretada con quien se
espera se encuentre el presidente
francés allí en Estados Unidos en este
segundo día
Pues mañana precisamente será el
encuentro oficial El encuentro de estado
que es el primer encuentro de estado que
tiene desde que llegó a la casa blanca
la casa blanca y muchas calles
importantes de la ciudad están con las
banderas francesas precisamente para
recibir darle la bienvenida de Manuel
macron que a las 9 de la mañana tendrá
Pues el saludo oficial este será en en
la terraza de la Casa Blanca después de
eso Pues será a las 10 de la mañana
habrá un habrá un encuentro oficial será
entonces en la reunión bilateral que
tendrán los dos mandatarios para después
a las 11:45 de la mañana ofrecer una
rueda de prensa donde los dos
mandatarios responderán preguntas acerca
de temas que usted y que muchos ya hemos
descrito acá que es el tema del cambio
climático y de la guerra contra Ucrania
que son dos de los principales temas que
trata en esta agenda y después por la
noche será la cena oficial donde estarán
las primeras damas y los vicepresidentes
respectivos de los países asistiendo en
la casa blanca de este evento